[Music]
insurgent is the sequel to divergent
which came out last year this is
actually a pretty quick sequel
development now that I think about it it
stars shailene woodley miles teller
Ansel Igor Theo James Kate Winslet and
it's the continuing Adventures of Tris
in this dystopian futuristic world in
which everything is broken up into
factions as we saw in the last film all
these characters are broken off into
various factions that are most suitable
for how they are as people there's a bit
of a civil war brewing amongst these
factions and Tris and her friends are
just trying to survive
now as for the first divergent I didn't
hate that movie I didn't think it was a
terrible movie it wasn't great or
anything and I've never watched it again
and I have no plans to but for the two
hours I sat in the theater I was
impressed with shailene Woodley's work
and the fact that it was better than
most book to film adaptations of these
y8 novels that I've been having to
experience and some adult novels that
I've had to experience more recently and
going into this movie I was a little bit
hopeful I loved shailene woodley as an
actress Naomi Watts is in the film she
is great Kate Winslet's a fantastic
actress and I was really intrigued by
the trailer in which she was hanging
from these wires that reminded me of the
ghost in the shell' poster which is one
of my favorite animes and I was hoping
for something that was more intense and
more dark than the original this film is
more intense there is more action and
the action is all filmed very well in
fact that's one of my biggest pluses for
this movie the director did a very good
job of filming the action scenes there's
a lot of Swift moving shots lots of long
takes there's no shaky cam to be found
anywhere and that really made me happy
Shailene Woodley is terrific as Tris
there's a lot of regret in her face a
lot of remorse you can really feel the
deep pain of her character and she did
an excellent job portraying that one of
the best scenes in this movie is when
she's forced to tell the truth about
some various things that she's very
ashamed of and that scene I thought was
fantastic and she really sold it my
issue with insurgent though is more
along the lines of the plot there's a
lot of things that happen in this movie
it's a very convoluted plot line and I
have friends that I saw the movie with
who read the books and our fans of the
books and even they said that a large
majority this movie was not in the book
and it felt a little bit jumbled so if
you are fans of the books you're more
than likely going to enjoy this movie
because you're already pumped for it
you're already excited for it but you
may be a little confused from what I
hear it
way that there's a lot of things in this
movie that weren't in the book to me
that's fine though because I like
surprises and I recognize that this is
an adaptation not everything is going to
be exactly like the book that being said
I wasn't really that invested in the
story of this movie because it does feel
very convoluted and it feels kind of
like a mishmash of ideas that looked
really good on paper and then they just
threw it at a wall and see where it
splattered and that's kind of how they
assembled a movie Kate Winslet is
amazing in her movies that she's done
before she's really really good in other
movies and she's not bad in this movie
it's just that there really isn't
anything for her to do she wanders
around through rooms she does kind of
sadistic tests on people as she tries to
weed through the various divergence that
she's looking for but it really just
evolves into a string of scenes in which
she wanders around a room has a
clipboard makes notes and says things in
a very dull and uncaring manner there
isn't really anything that menacing
about that so I didn't really feel her
presence as an antagonist was really all
that meaningful the best parts of this
movie are shailene woodley her character
the emotion she gives her character how
good her performance is and the fact
that the director did a really good job
of helming the action scenes but some of
those action scenes towards the end
especially during the simulation
sequences just look like shailene
woodley swinging around a green screen
room and it's really hard to feel like
you're actually watching a tangible
thing that's happening because it all
looks so well choreographed and so well
timed and so shiny and perfect that it
just looks kind of fake the best action
scene in this movie for me was an early
chase scene through the woods and onto a
train I thought that was very well
helmed but besides shailene woodley I
have to admit a lot of the performances
in this movie feel very wooden and
lifeless so much background and so much
depth was given to her character her
regret the things that she felt ashamed
of all the other characters felt very
cardboard cut-out cookie cutter
characters now something I've realized
over the past few years of doing a lot
of book to film reviews whether it's
divergent or Twilight or The Mortal
Instruments or fifty Shades of Grey or
The Hunger Games all of these
adaptations they all come with a very
strong fan base and you guys have a lot
of really strong opinions if you love
the book and you're already pumped out
of your mind for this movie just go
you'll
probably enjoy it as for me I'm going to
give insurgent a C+ despite having some
well directed action scenes and one very
good performance it's just not very
memorable for me I didn't find anything
about the film terribly remarkable and
it was very forgettable very fast guys
what are your thoughts on the last film
this film the book series whatever you
want to say sound off below and also
look forward to my upcoming new
hilarious 'ti review for jaws the
revenge
yeah jaws for that actually exists in
real life guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]